yeah welcome to this video I had some
technical issues with the the microphone
that's it this is why I'm late losing
about 30 seconds okay this is also why i
played c3m being irritated by all this
but okay here White has got an
interesting way to play with taking an
e-form immediately be using the center
you cannot take because of 25 and
probably you'll play Bishop / be 70 e
595 something like that but this looks
like a promising possession position for
white I at least I like it I've got them
good easy development some potential for
[ __ ] side plane
so castles I have Queenie for still
castles look sound like the normal move
maybe he's got something outs at five
million f5 takes it takes me okay it
damn didn't happen so Queenie fries
probably planning wait you cannot even
play a five so what is he doing then
after this move really well this looks
ugly okay so Bishop age six am with
temple shouldn't be bad and how to
continue now does he threaten to move
the noise I don't think he does so I can
complete development first you move the
night I can take b7 and also a a [ __ ]
this sudden move like night before and
start working so i want to go here
anyway
and the idea is now the very simple h4
h5 yep I don't think I want to do I want
to take it's not bad really but this
this should be ok h4 h5 this is really
good enough so night see form let's
let's let's go ahead with this first
ok
yeah probably needs to go kingi 70
huh so we want to play with Jade I
understand still it look some really
ugly okay so rook rook some rook to e1
maybe a because I 195 maybe he does he
threaten to take maybe he does with Ruby
g8 coming
okay i try to get in 96 so that I have
not f7 this possibility okay here we go
yeah very simple but should be should be
okay too threatening neither 7 how does
he what okay can go to g7 let's not text
X key night f7 takes takes King g7
Queen g5 kf7 takes checks yeah it's
really it looks like it looks really bad
but maybe it is okay okay if i move the
Queen he will play 95 I play h6 now
threatening night f7 you can also take
you five this is real annoyance so I
probably need to do this yeah yeah if it
manages to wriggle out of this would be
really disappointing after all this okay
why doesn't he take Kim g7 is made age
six mate okay so probably not Queen here
I could have gone gone to h4 maybe maybe
h4 would have been better
yeah maybe not much I can do about it no
I dis look you fall and you may be
taking on f1 somehow getting this piece
and 2 into the attack
yeah I'm gracia and he's got two pieces
for the rook it's it's not so so really
super easy to play for him but so
certainly better for four black
I can always go to g5
threatened to take now yeah let's go
here
95 here oh yeah this is really unlucky
it looked quite quite dangerous too
maybe maybe there wasn't anything
anything serious but check it is still
not clear really what check I'll take
that
now you can do not age three but I don't
mind
you
so he's got got no threats basically
mm-hmm I hope time h5 maybe check check
he's got last one second left in kind
yeah probably the result that was okay
after move 15 or something but not but
this should be it should be excellent
for white really around here I cannot
believe this also Queen a tree just wins
computer says okay yeah it doesn't
surprise me it looks really fishy Queen
h3 now because I take on g6 mm-hmm I
should have seen that here just this one
after night eggs I have this sound yeah
this is really easy black won't survive
that and it gets some it gets the desert
results I mean after this opening set up
black really should be in trouble
allowing all this is really a bit much
but I let him into the game i probably
had a winning position at one point okay
yeah well thanks an interesting game I
think